malgré une audience assez assez faible
de la série sur des maisons de négoce
les gens font la grimace ça va pas
marcher deux millions et quelques places
et du million trois cent mille télé
c'est leur leader sur les femmes
responsables des achats les plus
importants pour m6 et se positionner
deuxième de la soirée
si j'attendais donc en fait pour vous
pour m6 c'est une bonne opération c'est
une bonne opération une opération qui
reprend mardi prochain avec les deux
derniers épisodes mini-série de quatre
fois 52 minutes
alors on va regarder un extrait c'est
l'extrait où justement celui qui est
censé être et xavier dupont de ligonnès
s'apprête à utiliser son arme et il veut
des conseils regarder ces sept ans vous
me donniez votre avis j'aimerais avoir
quelques précisions
elle n'est pas chargée bien sûr c'est
parfait vous l'avez pas fait ont nettoyé
séquelles vous savez si c'est possible
d'adapter un silencieux wee chuté
jusqu'à nous le permet mais si inutile
pourquoi un 22 long rifle et
pratiquement aucun bruit c'est important
que je rentre c'est totalement
opérationnel elle l'est tout ça reste
autonome et je dois défendre ma famille
sont en danger
c'est mon rôle vous savez je suis un
homme d'église je suis presque prête
on peut dire que je suis un prêtre
tireur voilà alors ça c'était un excès
qui a fait et qui a fait parler
christopher genou sent agacé énervé
alors c'est au delà de ça ou alors
calmez vous quand même mais pour moi
c'était une daube et les visuels comme
j'ai rarement vu mal écrit mal joué
apparemment du cru et qui s'en sort pas
mal écrit mal joué l'an sur pour hi fi
il y avait toutes les cases de l'adobe à
cocher pour moi ce même louis le pks de
l'adouber case pour moi je préfère
garder encore un épisode de louis la
brocante c'est magnifique monsieur le
père j'ai pas dit que monsieur l'auteur
n'est pas possible de rentrer dedans
c'est globalement alor également haut ce
que tout le monde à dire on a on voit là
ya pas d je rejoins pas du tout sûr
arnaud ducret parce que j'ai trouvé à
côté du début à la fin
j ai pas cru une minute ben je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé je amende et j'ai
pensé que c'était un télé qui déconnait
ou qui avait après deux bouts
c'est la première fois que ça m'arrive
impossible de rentrer dans un truc et
c'est vrai alors on va regarder un autre
excès qui a fait qui a fait parler parce
que c'est en fait c'est la partie
fictionné c'est le moment où xavier
dupont de ligonnès va acheté de la chaux
des pelles etc pour préparer son coup et
dans la dans le téléfilm il fait des
courses avec son fils ça ça n'est pas
arrivé dans la vraie vie
regardez le rouleau adhésif là-bas au
large et gris une quinzaine non une
vingtaine passée bien ça ils m'appellent
[Musique]
c'est un coup de propre à la terrasse au
jardin le trop longtemps que c'est
dégueulasse dans les marques mais c'est
une super idée ça c'est bientôt le
printemps tout c'est le moment idéal
j'en suis sûr je pourrais donner un coup
de main si tu veux
[Musique]
et donc beaucoup de gens sont interrogés
sur l'intérêt de cette séquence en tous
les cas fait comme ça ma gueule et berna
n'aime pas non plus parce que je trouve
que la fiction ça rajoute de l'horreur à
l'horreur en fait on n'a pas besoin d'en
rajouter
ces macabres c'est encore c'est
dégueulasse comme histoire en bas se
mentir et de la rajouter de la fiction
autour de ça en plus alors que le gars
n'a pas été arrêté il est encore fugitif
et moi dans ma tête je me dis quoi
je suis téléspectatrices et je m'imagine
ce gars dans son canapé en train de
regarder un film sur lui il ya peu jean
innovant canapé à regarder maintenant
mais ystari si une personne qui aimait
son nom aujourd'hui c'est le son nom
c'est le titre du film sa star ici à un
mec qui est encore en cavale
on n'a pas le la 110 warhola pas la fin
de l'histoire et je trouve que c'est
honteux
voilà ce qu'est ce qui est un peu
embêtant on se trouve dans ce film il
faut ça alors on est tous d'accord on a
tous l'idée que c'est lui le meurtrier
mais jusqu'à nouvel ordre selon la loi
française il est présumé innocent et je
trouve qu'on entre guillemets dans le
film en même si on a tous cet avis
d'arrondi c'est lui c'est lui c'est lui
et je trouve cette benne au mieux sauter
le tout et tout et tous les faisceaux
prouve que oui c'est pas lui voilà c'est
par rapport à voile à la loi française
sert les nationaux comme sexuelle dans
cette histoire j'attends les connais
rien mais moi je trouve qu'on s'en fout
que ce soit pas hyper bien joué c'est
pas de la starification c'est m6 qui
surf et ils ont bien raison sur une
affaire on a tous dans le coeur on a
tous envie de savoir ce qui s'est passé
et donc du coup c'est juste du buzz pour
le buzz mais c'était pas si
catastrophique que ça
et à chaque fois qu'on parle dupont de
ligonnès êtes tous là où je suis excité
et là comme par hasard elle n'a plus un
intérêt mais moi ça mérite et je trouve
que c'était plutôt malin de la part de
m6 on foule soit mal joué la dernière
extrait qu'on va regarder insula il a
fait beaucoup parler parce que si vous
connaissez l'histoire de xavier dupont
de ligonnès en fait les corps ont été
enterrés sous la terrasse
alors pourquoi dans le téléfilm qui
l'ont mis sa sous un abri de jardin
je ne sais pas en tous les cas ça fait
beaucoup parler regardez
jeudi 21 mai 2011 deezer 45e position
nous fouillons sous l'appentis c'est
cool
on dirait du ciment n'est pas tout à
fait ça cas en dessous nouvelle couche
de faire mes toiles assez épaisse
blanche c'est ça
maintenant la bulle des coupes à carrer
de 40 cm sur 40 cm
[Musique]